Speaker 1: Our voicemail number is 219 to David
P. You can call any time and ask about anything.
Here is a really interesting question
that relates directly to what I was
just saying about the voters of Georgia.
Speaker 3: Hi, David, it's James. I just wanted
to know, how do you feel about voter shaming?
I know that. You know a couple of things. Kyle
and Mike Figueredo and a few other people.
I think Young Turks are generally against
voter shaming, like, you know, criticized
from voters because they voted for Trump.
But they'll sometimes criticize people who
voted for Trump because of the wall or because
of, you know, the fact that he said banning banned
Muslims or, you know, Mexicans are rapists and all
that. How do you feel about voters? Do you think
it's productive? Do you think it's fair? Or do you
think it's better to just stick to criticizing the
politicians? But, you know, because I basically,
I. I want to find out the best way.
Speaker 1: Okay. Yes. Right. So what? So so,
listen, there's two things going on
here, all right? If you're asking me,
do y think it's inbounds, so to speak, for on
programs like mine, to be very frank and candid
and direct about the fact that there is a lot
of dumb people in this country and many of them
don't know what the hell is going on. And they're
just bamboozled by these politicians with obvious
lies and they fall for it and they vote for them.
And how do they even put their pants on in the
morning? How do you balance a checkbook if you are
so ignorant about just basic things you're being
lied to on? I have no problem as a commentary on
this program saying stuff like that. And in fact,
I've said there's really three main groups of
Trump voters. There are people who just don't
know what the hell is going on. They don't know.
They don't know what Trump policies are. They just
don't know anything. And they were kind of like
tricked. They stumbled into voting for Trump.
There's people who are what we might call like
bad people. They do understand the Trump policy
and they understand all of the things that
happened as a result and all the people that
Trump policy is terrible for and they say, I
like it and I'm going to vote for him anyway.
And then you've got the third group, which is
people who vote for Trump out of some selfish
priority. Well, yeah, I understand exactly who
and what Trump is, but his tax plan would save
me money, so I'm going to vote for him. Those
are the main three groups of Trump voters. I've
been totally upfront about that, so I have
no issue about shows like mine doing that.
On the other hand, I am aware that as a matter of
pragmatics and effectively deprogramming people
from, for example, Trumpism. If I were running
a campaign right. And I was Trump's opponent,
I don't think that shaming Trump voters
would be the right way to win them over.
Right. I would take an approach that would be
something more like, listen, I understand that
because we have so much work to do in this
country to really make it what it could be.
I understand the desire when something different
pops up and Trump was different. To find in that
a reflection of your own desires about the reality
that this could be a better country. I understand
that. But we tried it and it failed. And I can
tell you exactly what would make this country
better. And it's what I'm offering. And I welcome
you to come to me no matter who you voted for last
time around. That framing, which is you're not
shaming anybody. You're actually saying, I get
what was going on that made you say, I don't know,
this is different. Maybe it's better. That is more
effective than saying there's a lot of stupid
people here. There are a lot of stupid people
here. And for a program like mine, it's different
than if you're running a national campaign. So
that's my view on voter shaming. I hope I'm sort
of explaining it clearly. We have a great bonus
show for you today sign up it joined Pacman
dot com and I will see you on the bonus track.